hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast predictive biomarkers to
diagnostic test scientific and
regulatory consideration in development
of companion diagnostic tests presented
by our keynote speaker John akivi
Raghavan she is a biologist at the
office of inventor diagnostics and
radiological health at the Center for
Devices at the US Food and Drug
Administration
I am Marjorie Torres of labyrinth and I
will be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
Reed's lab Ruth's is leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hear in the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom or center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credit tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
John Oakey via raghava I will now turn
the presentation over to her Thank You
Marjorie and it's a pleasure to talk at
the virtual event hosted by lab root as
much we described at the talk mainly
outlines how you convert a paddock to
biomarker discovered in research to a
companion diagnostic test or or any
diagnostic test for that matter but this
talk will focus on our regulatory
considerations for developing companion
diagnostic
I will go through the talk as such is
divided into three uh three distinct
categories or topics so to speak in the
first place I will go through what would
be an FDA 101 for most of the audience
we will go over the regulatory pathways
and the ways you a developer could reach
out to the FDA to seek feedback or and
since I work with mostly oncology
devices and companion diagnostic to date
are dominated by the oncology fields and
given the interest in immuno oncology
I'm going to take the examples of some
diet C test that was approved by FDA
over the last few years and use them as
a case study for describing how we come
to regulatory decisions and also
important to keep in mind is how and
what FDA means by analytical validation
I will spend a significant amount of
time talking about that and towards the
end of the talk I'll go over some of the
complexities is there in how Diagnostics
are rapidly evolving and what FDA is
doing to stay nimble and make sure
patients have access to the latest
technologies and and are therapies that
are being discovered out in the field ah
but that I think one of the first most
important things to recognize is the
difference between a biomarker was as a
diagnostic test how a biomarker is
anything that can be measured or to
indicate a disease take and back in the
day you could think of this as probably
the sugar in urine and it could also be
a test that measures the response to a
therapeutic but biomarkers mostly exist
in the exploratory space or in the
research space and given that it is in
the exploratory space are the test
systems might not be defined there might
be multiple different ways of measuring
an analyte or
biomarker and that stopped us and it is
not very well specified so there are
multiple ways to approach the biomarker
in contrast a diagnostic test is well
defined and it is intended for diagnosis
of disease and to identify to identify
appropriate treatment options for
patients and a diagnostic test is also
specific in the sense that it defines
the entire system from the specimen type
whether you're measuring the analyte in
blood in urine or in tissue in the case
of oncology and if that tissue type is
now fixed in formalin or alcohol or is
it frozen all of them ah so it defines
the specimen type starts with the
definition of the specimen types the
reagents that is used and it also goes
all were draw the methodology or the
protocol used to arrive at a result the
instruments and the software involved to
keep a test running in order to get a
result and diagnostic tests are also
ones where we know the performance we
know what the sensitivity and
specificity of the test is or its
predictive value whether getting a test
result that's positive Havoc's a disease
stage or response to a therapy so
diagnostic tests are extremely well
defined and this will be a kind of a
touchstone which I'll come back to a few
times throughout the talk so how our
diagnostic device is regulated by the
Food and Drug Administration it is a
risk based regulation and there are
three classes of risks class 1 class 2
and class 3 in this slide I don't
appoint to class 1 devices because
they're exempt from a day oversight
whereas class 2 and class 3 devices fall
under our purview and what is the class
to do I so class 1 devices are Lourdes
devices where the risk associated with
along with prong result is
relatively small whereas a class 2
device carries a moderate risk and class
two devices are then regulated by what
is called a traditional 510k pathway and
the fighting pay pathway gives clearance
our marketing clearance for diagnostic
tests to be marketed then it shows
substantial substantial equivalence to
an legally marketed predicate so a prior
test exists of which then the new test
can show that it is substantially
equivalent to and would obtain an FDA
clearance these are for moderate risk
test whereas class 3 devices a high risk
test and they go through a pathway
called the pre-market approval
application the PMA applications are
reviewed and approved by the FDA by the
FDA based on demonstration of safety and
effectiveness and I will go over what
safety and effectiveness Azur it'll get
it'll be more clear as we go through the
talk so plus T devices are hiders
devices and almost all oncology
applications for companion diagnostics
fall under this category currently oh
and a third route called the de novo
fight and Cape as they exist where there
are no predicates available so you have
developed a new test and you believe
it's a moderate risk device and it could
easily fall into a class to where the
regulatory burden is somewhat lower than
a class three device then you come in
through a petition called the de novo
fight and k pathway where draw FDA
accesses it for their existing no
predicate for it and the determination
of safety and effectiveness as we do for
the PMA approval and then propose a set
of special controls and authorize the
marketing of the test and classify the
analyte into a class to if it is
appropriate so these are the three major
regulatory pathway and given that the
talk focuses on companion diagnostic
much of what I say today will be applied
to the class three devices that you see
on the right of your screen so why is
companion diagnostics exciting when you
look at look to the
right you can see blindfolded scientists
shooting in the dark which was there
before targeted therapy and a
development of targeted therapies
existed where the efficacy was in the
overall population was poor however when
targeted therapy was was developed or
came into the market as a big car or
pathway to developing oncology drugs um
it became apparent that you need that
precision medicine our being able to
identify people to move to the right of
the screen where you're able to target
with high effectiveness are the patients
who are actually likely to respond to
drug treatment it became apparent that
you need accurate reproducible and
clinically useful companion diagnostics
to make precision medicine our deliver
on its promise so that's what makes
companion diagnostics important are in
the coming era so that we deliver the
drugs to the people who need it and have
high efficacy out of it
so the Food and Drug Administration
issued a guidance in August of 2014
which defines companion diagnostic as a
test that provides information that's
essential for the safe and effective use
of a corresponding therapeutic and does
the guidance document lays out FDA
policies offer approval and labeling and
I think I would like to note at this
point is that all companion diagnostic
applications are contemporaneously
reviewed as the drug approval goes
through and you will see the
implications of that in the next slide
so a companion diagnostic is being
developed to identify patients who will
respond to a therapeutic which means the
development of the drug which is a
pointed to at the bottom of the screen
that starts in the research stage and
the left when target selection and drug
selection and validation the device or
the
that needs to come in as a companion
diagnostic has to be developed in
parallel such that early in development
the biomarker that needs to be converted
to a diagnostic product is identified
if the biomarker is identified the best
test for ah for segregating responders
and non-responders our potential
responders and non-responders has to be
cut off so the test at this time could
be anything it could be a it could be an
analyte in blood it could be a measure
of a protein or in the serum or it could
be a a DNA mutation it could be an IC IC
by identification of a biomarker by IHC
in the tissue sections so at this stage
is when this when the choice of test and
a protocol to identify it should be are
thoroughly researched and this is
followed by a stage where analytical
validation of the test needs to be
performed by analytical validation we
need to understand the parameters within
which are the tests performs
reproducibly that it gives out the right
exact same results with high precision
and reproducible results over multiple
testing over time and I'll come over to
the specifics of analytical validation
later in my presentation as I had
mentioned so in the preclinical and
early clinical stage the analytical
validation of the device ha should be
undertaken and finally once the assay is
the technology the specimen the platform
and a cut point is identified this asset
now needs to be clinically validated and
this is where the clinical utility of
both the drug and device ID established
in a clinical trial of and previously it
used to happen all the three phases on
the Phase three would be a physical
trial but in this new era of
exciting new drugs coming to market this
might happen earlier in development such
as a phase two study so one needs to be
prepared for it and in the in under the
analytical validation arrow you see
three three are three words
it's called register R Prasad IDE and
PMA and your I've told you about PMA is
the pre market application but typically
comes at the end of the pivotal clinical
trial of pivotal clinical trial but
before coming to a PMA application one
needs to also look at uh uh whether
there are earlier points of interaction
with the agency and the earlier points
of interaction of the agency could be as
early as when you start analytical
validation of the test and this happens
to be uh this can happen through a
process called pre submission or to
submission with the Center for Devices
and another important question that is
triggered is an investigational device
exemption of and the question a
developer needs to ask is since it's a
human subject research involved is an
investigational device exemption needed
and an investigational device exemption
or an IDE application may be needed if a
diagnostic test for a biomarker is used
to identify a select of patients to a
drug trial and the ideally requirement
is based on risk to patients so does the
use of the test and the results from the
test pose a significant risk or a non
significant risk to patients health and
one can determine that one can identify
whether the investigation in which the
device is going to be validated would be
a significant risk for a non significant
risk by submitting our pre submission
application to the CDRH and it's a
relatively painless process it takes
about thirty days for us to turn around
or less than thirty days for us to turn
around and say if one would need ninety
application or not for a given clinical
trial
and so I talked about what happens at
the end of performing a pivotal trial
and the question that most often comes
up is oh we have a biomarker
we don't know whether this is going to
need a companion diagnostic application
or should we bring the application in
and so the question that is necessary to
answer is oh if is this a biomarker
selective trial bill and in in vitro
diagnostic device or a test for the
biomarker result be required for safe
and essential use are safe and effective
use of the therapeutic product if the
answer is yes it probably triggers the
need for a companion diagnostic
application but the decision for
requirement of a companion diagnostic is
a joint position from drug and device
review divisions in cedar and CDRH so
all of these reviews starting from when
the drug application comes in for an IND
or investigational new drug application
investigational new drug application or
raw or an IDE or investigational device
exemption application all these reviews
are conducted contemporaneously between
sida and CDRH and the review division is
work very closely together to answer
these questions more recently a new term
a complementary diagnostic has come into
play and I will touch upon this again
later in my talk but I want to lay down
here the difference between the two a
companion diagnostic is essential for
the safe and effective use of the
corresponding therapeutic product as we
have previously defined and I'll be
using the examples of PDA one IHC trying
to see 3 down the road what is the
complementary ivt complimentary IV D is
more is a new attack the newer category
of diagnostic devices for a therapeutic
product and this diagnostic device our
test identifies population for which the
use of the therapeutic product has a
different benefit risk profile so the
drug
can the device can identify different
genres condoms whether it is improved
response in positive or increased risk
to a side effect so either a safety risk
or of our increased efficacy in a
subgroup of the patient population um
and so how does FDA review a companion
diagnostic test or what are the
components of a companion diagnostic
test that is reviewed by FDA so like I
told you at the very beginning of my
talk are the essential the risk base of
the device is based on the intended use
of the indications of use so that is a
key component of the device that we look
at then within that we expect the
application to include device
description are the reagents the
instrument platforms that I used pre
analytical factors that may impact test
results the analytical performance the
clinical performance the instrumentation
and software that are required for
generating a test result we also review
the labeling or the package insert for
the device and given that most companion
diagnostics are a class 3 devices it
also requires a quality systems review
in the GRP and buy more for bio research
monitoring these are all the components
of an FDA review of a companion
diagnostic and at this point I'd like to
say that the two key components of
review are the clinical performance and
analytical performance I will go over
clinical performance which is the most
critical component of the device saw
devices ability to show safety and
effectiveness and then go over
analytical performance requirements that
FDA places so how do you validate for
clinical or a diagnostic tasks in a
clinical trial so the clinical
validation of the device is typically
done in the pivotal trial for
therapeutic product because the
companion
diagnostic and in this case the device
is used to test patients specimens our
Toledo stratify or to identify patients
who are eligible for the therapeutic
clinical trial and for the analytical
validation these studies have to be done
with an eye towards a clinical decision
point I will we will go over clinical
decision point a few slides down where I
will give you a detailed description of
what exactly so what else does one need
ha think of when you are beginning
analytical validation I had talked about
earlier how a diagnostic device is
extremely well define the tests used to
select the target population and roll
into the clinical trial should specify
the specimen type that will be used for
testing it should identify the specific
test whether it's a PCR and IHC NGS or
what technology is going to be used it
should specify the protocol that goes
with the test that will be used and a
clinical decision find so if it's a
quantitative a say in what ranges will
the patient selection apply if it's a
qualitative I'll say what is what is
what is a cut-off at which a patient
specimen is deemed positive or negative
this is very important because
ultimately we are trying to determine
the precision of an assay and the
precision typically around a
pre-specified cutoff
also to keep in mind before entering her
phase three pivotal trial the cutoff
should be pre specified and logged down
at the assay fully locked down by the
assay being fully locked down these we
mean all these four components are in
place and are not modified as the trial
goes on and what to do try and be
determining what it would be so keeping
in mind the intended use population
should develop the study design that is
used to support the diagnostic claim and
so you also one also needs to put in
place pre specified
statistical analysis plan and establish
an appropriate endpoint for a surrogate
endpoint that will be choosen at the
edge successes are to be determined and
typically analytical validation should
precede clinical validation and what are
the choices for in terms of clinical
trial design are for for determining
whether your test is safe and effective
so since it's a companion diagnostic we
are talking about this can be determined
in two different type of clinical trials
the first one is a targeted or marker
positive only trial and any time a
marker positive only trial is picked up
a companion diagnostic becomes essential
for safe and effective use because that
is the only population patient
population in which the drug effect has
been characterized absolutely the drug
trial could also be all-comers such that
not all patients in the intent to treat
population are eligible irrespective of
their biomarker status and the types of
data one derives from the diagnostic
clinical trial is determination of the
sensitivity and specificity in
Alzheimer's trial and positive and
positive character value and negative
predictive value for therapeutic effect
in the biomarker select population in a
targeted clinical trial so as I spoke
before I will be using immunotherapy
approvals as a case study for this
presentation and as many of you would be
aware of this is an extremely happening
field of clinical research in oncology
and so far there are five different
drugs that all target the PD while PDL
one axis that have been approved in more
than a handful of indications and to be
clear this table was not updated
recently and their list of approvals is
much longer than the list of approval in
different indications as much longer
than the ones I presented here
so and when you look at this table all
the error all the indications are
against which there are asterisks
present are ones where our companion or
a complementary diagnostic has been
approved for use are in this patient
population and are there in fact more
and I'm here is a comprehensive table
that lists all the Diagnostics that have
been approved in the immunotherapy area
by the FDA we have companion diagnostics
for katroo de which is the mug drug that
targets PD one and is paired with the
deco PDL one IHC tried to see three from
the ex test this has been approved as a
companion diagnostic in lung as well as
gastric cancer and we have three
additional tasks for identifying PDL one
in each of these cases PDL one is the
target analyte and we have three
additional tests one more by deco and
two additional ones by Ventana for up
devatta centric and M Finzi each of
which are used to identify patients with
the indications in the second but last
column to the right I would like to draw
your attention to the last column on the
right which is titled the clinical
cutoff what would what you should bear
in mind is that each of these assays
have a different definition of what
constitutes of PDL one positive patient
are a PDA one positive tumor for any
given patient if you look at the top two
lines for the same device the deco PDL
wat ready to see three pharmd acts in
the lung indications are there are two
cut-offs the greater than 50% are tumor
proportion score in the first line and
greater than 1% humor proportion score
in second line or later and this does
identify patients who are eligible for
treatment in the first line or in the
second line and in the case of gastric
so it uses a entirely different scoring
system called combined proportion score
which includes tumor and immune cells
the tumor proportion scores includes
only the tumor cells so here's an
example of far the 2264 DX in tender
greens it's a very busy slide and I know
it's hard to read what I'd like you to
concentrate on are the box titles and
the atoms describe one exactly each of
these means so and an intended use
statement and I you statement is a
comprehensive description of the device
where the test is supposed to be applied
how its performed and what does it
actually do so in the first part you can
see that it identifies the unlike it
says it's an IFC test the tech ID ID
Flags the technology in the opening it
Flags the analyte that's going to be
detected the matrix are the specimen
type that is used for the test and the
test system the invision flexes the
detection reagent and the auto strainer
link for EI does the instrument reagents
and instruments in to involved in
identifying PDL one and as you move to
which conditions it's use there it flags
that for non small cell lung cancer
period one status is defined by two
multiple score and in green is the
description of how the tumor proportion
score is arrived at and you also flag
the calf white for a TPS greater than
one our Tier one high GPA is greater
than fifty which are the indicators of
clinical cutoff and finally so if you do
this test and run it and take into
consideration the clinical cutoff what
are you doing you are using this test as
an aid in identifying lung cancer
patient well
for treatment September loosen map so
this is what Flags it as a companion
diagnostic and this is the intended use
of the test and you can see there are
similar language embedded within the
gastric and gastroesophageal Junction
indication for which this drug approval
is less so
the intended use our statement gives you
a complete picture or a comprehensive
picture of how the test is used so how
did one arrive at the a companion
diagnostic claim this was based on
keynote the trials that were conducted
and originally the the keynote trial was
based on objective response rates I here
I forget the the clinical trial name in
which it was determined but I object to
response rates in PDL one patients
greater than fifty percent of tumors
expressed PDL one was used to support
the companion diagnostic claim and later
the same study updated the data for
overall survival in patients that had
tumor proportion score of greater than
one but you were proportion score it
means all tumor cells that Express PDL
one so using that as a marker the
increase in response as you can see on
the curve in the right here in second
line patients who had in patients who
had received more than one line of
treatment for their primary for
non-small-cell lung cancer when compared
to those attacks had higher survival
rates and the so higher survival rate
was preserved irrespective of the drug
concentration used ah the studies did
not explore the activity of the drug in
patients who were negative or had no PDL
one expression that kind of logged into
the idea that this is a companion
diagnostics that the efficacy of the
drug in Amaka negative population is
unknown
similarly in overall survival for first
life the clinical study was conducted
based on selecting patient's that had
greater than 50% of the tumour cells
expressing PDL 1 and they saw high
efficacy in that group when compared to
chemotherapy and improved overall
survival rates since these trials were
marker selective trials when since these
are the market I'll listen these were
Marcos elective trials this already
automatically fell into the companion
diagnostic paradigm I talked about a
complementary diagnostic ah
earlier and even that there were
multiple clinical trials with multiple
drugs at that time this is a good
example to go over how a complementary
is different than a companion
complementary diagnostic tests are was
approved for novel math and this
complementary diagnostic approval of is
so it has been for for different
indications long had an accurate ileal
cancer as well as melanoma and if you
look at the look at the written portion
of the slide what you can see is that
similar to the companion diagnostic the
first part of the intended you statement
describes the test and the score and the
second part here in this case is are in
a tabular format given that there are
four indications for which shut the
complementary diagnostic approval
exercises now you can see that the
portions of the text under intended use
column that are in red shows the
language of slightly different here the
intended yield states that PDL one
expression as detected by the 2088 farm
DX test in non small cell lung or
squamous cell carcinoma of the head and
neck may be associated with enhanced
survival so in this case it doesn't say
that you have to be pedia one positive
to get the drug what it says is that if
you express PDL 1 positive are the
effect of the drug might be associated
with the enhanced survival
I will I will talk a little bit more
about the melanoma trial there the
intended new statement is correlated
with magnitude of treatment effect on
progression-free survival from our table
so this was a three on trial where from
patients who had melanoma and had no
prior therapy had no prior therapy
Albert and rose and treated with either
no Illuma animal damar but it gloomy map
or if you will never know and as you can
see on the left in patients with less
than one percent P do one expression a
new one heart was more effective than a
balloon bath but the combination was
appear to be not appear to have more
effect whereas if you look at P P R cos
in PDL 1 greater than 1 what you see is
that both new Olam haba nivolumab in
combination with a bloomer map show
higher higher efficacy than if you live
not alone and what is more striking is
that for patients treated with mono
therapy the left in PDL 1 1 percent
population new Vollmar is less effective
than combination but i'm greater than 1
percent population in the world map is
almost as effective as the combination
that's why we say that there is an
increased magnitude of expression in a
intended use and this is the data based
on which are the approval for the
complementary diagnostic was issued so
moving on
having an understanding of what
companion and complementary diagnostics
are I'd like to go into go into some of
the factors that impact our assessment
of or the review of a PMA application Oh
so slide trouble some of the factors
that impact up review of far-off Oh
PMA application is uh the clinical trial
assay Oh
so we escaped emphasizing in my talk
that our finalized lock down as they
should be used for enrollment of filling
the subject and the Sun and the task
that's used for enrollment or clinical
subjects is called the clinical trials
assay and the market-ready assay is the
assay that will be pushed out or
supplied to the market how do these two
match up and what is the definition of
the clinical cutoff and the scoring
methodology used to determine the
biomarkers status we hope that this is
logged down in the temper trial as well
and exploration of multiple points these
are factors that tend to impact ah how
how PMA reviews are affected so what
what happens if the clinical trial assay
is not the same as the market ready
assay which is the subject of a PMA
application if the clinical trial assay
that was used to enroll patients is not
identical to the market ready assay then
a bridging study is required to show the
equivalency are the performance being
the same for a clinical trial assay on
the market ready assay so why would this
happen this might happen because more
than one version of for clinical trial
assay was used to enroll patients
because the test itself was still under
development as a clinical trial progress
I lost my place
um are multiple lab cats might have been
used and pre-screening for the biomarker
might have been done at local sides such
that many different assets were used to
end all clinical trial patients and uh
with trial device changes were made
because research information indicated
that there was either a problem with the
secondary agent or the cutoff did not
appear to be appropriate and uh
sometimes you have clinical trial asses
that have inadequate validation and
require major modifications at the end
of the trial and sometimes Oxford's
stability issues just that our asset
specific for IHC's can bring about to
bring about differences in clinical
trial assay and the market-ready Asuna
ah so anticipating these challenges down
the road is essential for a successful
law develop pitiful companion diagnostic
and the best way to do that is to have a
robust plan for specific ninety
retrieval and retesting so anticipating
that you will require retesting of these
persons are is a good plan going forward
and how do you do a bridging study a
bridging study will retest ah all
clinical trial positive and uh some of
the clinical trial negative if it's a
matter of selected population with the
new order wise test to support safety
and efficacy of the therapeutic product
and one should ensure that in a bridging
study the retest population is
representative of the intended use
population for the device and since a
bridging study is being conducted one
should also have a statistical analysis
plan to take into account any
discordance from test results from the
clinical trial assay to mark
ready assay and you should also think
about samples going missing for the
bridging study suppose the patient
deposited in our specimens only for the
clinical trial assay there and there is
an inability to retest with the market
ready assay you have missing samples and
a fantastical analysis plan that
accounts for all this can give you a
robust of an a robust assessment of
equivalency or rot e equal MC of the
clinical trial assay and the market
ready assay and it's also impact it
should also address bias and the impact
of this of any such biases due to
missing specimens are discarded on a
reputed product efficacy so the second
cut part the second second point that I
raised that might impact our point for a
device is that top of a review of a PMA
is that the clinical cut point becomes
important the clinical cut point is
ideally explored in phase one and phase
two of the study and as I mentioned
before the asset should be loved up and
the cut point please specify if the cut
point is is modified during the trial it
should definitely not be based on test
based on results or unblinding of the
outcomes in the clinical trial in which
are the diagnostic devices being
validated so the validation of the
device should not be based on subgroup
exploration within the study in which
it's being validated so independent test
and validation sample sets are essential
for a point validation and combining of
data from test and validation cohorts
are saying that I have a cohort a in
which I explored the cut point and I am
validating this in cohort be within the
same clinical trial you cannot establish
all outcomes based on combining cohort a
hobby that's an example of how
you don't combine data to validate the
performance of the dogs and if
exploration of multiple cut offs such
that subjects are stratified based on
multiple cut offs and I'll give you an
example in my next slide it is possible
to do that especially in all commerce
studies if our test results are defined
well defined and stratification factors
specify that all these test results will
be used however one needs to keep in
mind that if there are multiple cut off
things for analytical validation should
be performed around each cut off one of
the biggest examples that I can give
from come from approved or diagnostic
devices complimentary is the 28 a da say
that's complementary for neural map in
Mon squamous non-small cell lung cancer
in those clinical study the efficacy of
the drug was measured in patients of
groups who had PDL 1 less than 1% PDR 1
greater than 1% PDL water less than 5
percent greater than 5 percent less than
10% impenitence
however the clinical trials try to fight
our subjects as they enrolled into the
study such that the two arms had even
representation of all of pd alone
expression at each level and there were
not imbalances and the analytical
validation that went with this validated
all 3 cut points for the device so next
I'd like to touch upon something that is
very specific to the PDL one IHC test
and that is the complexity of scoring
and this is a unique issue for IHC test
results and how positivity is defined
are the clinical cutoff is different the
fine and the implications of what the
clinical cutoff is then it's varied for
us for the same analyte across multiple
drugs and as you can see in this table
here when you concentrate on the
clinical cutoff and the cell types code
oh you see that for octavo enormous
cases tumor cells is called and a score
of better than one five or ten percent
is considered PDA one positive for lung
indication whereas for melanoma are
greater than one percent is an is
considered PDA one positive and it's a
dichotomous and not a continuous score
unlike for lon
so within a single drug device pair
there are two different definitions of
PDL or positivity then you move to a
another drug device pair and kepler-22
c3 in this case in the first line long
greater than 50% tumor proportions cause
our tumor cells being scored as positive
means your PDA one positive and if
you're not a first-line subject but
you've had more than one lines of
treatment then your PDL one positivity
level drops to greater than 1% and this
is a lot of information for pathologists
and community practitioners to hold in
their head in terms of how how Pieria
one possibility is described but the
average complexity in the PDL one field
comes from the use of our incorporation
of the immune cells into the scoring
system and men immune cells incorporated
into the scoring system it's done in
many different ways and for IC scoring
by the Ventana SP 142 and SP 263 assays
it is defined by the percentage of tumor
area occupied by two PDA one positive
immune cells whereas pi speak to vi
agree it's a two-step evaluation first
the amount of tumor area that's occupied
by infiltrating immune cells is assessed
and the percentage of that percentage
immune input rate occupied cells that
are PDL were positive and these are
percent areas mind you these are not
percentage of immune cells a percentage
of tumor cells that are positive so
there is a lot of granularity and
differences and how these things called
and given that these asses identify the
same analyte it could be easy to unto
think that these assays are equivalent
and that a lung cancer
with any one of these four assays was
going to give you the same answer but
the clinical validation for these tests
have been done at very well-defined
scores and that means that the clinical
outcomes that are being reported in the
labels applied only to the scores as as
defined by the diagnostic drug maker
with the tests of interest and how these
map are are still an area of active
research at this point and I want to
spine doubt that Phuket rooder of while
the lung indications use tumor portion
scores are the gastric indication uses
and combined proportion score which
takes into account all PDA 1 positive
tumor cells and immune cells as a
proportion of all tumor cells multiplied
by hundred
so each system carries its own scoring
differences that in turn in fact I've
gone over the slide that in great detail
before so I'm going to skip over that so
when when we have seen multiple
applications using different definitions
of positivity for for this for a single
analyte what are the issues that FDA
faces in assessing of the safety and
effectiveness of a device um we do not
make any any assessment of the
compatibility of the four devices each
device is approved as a standalone and
how it performs in association with the
drug in which with which it was fed in a
clinical trial and that is the extent of
it for us the review challenges remain
in how the PDA one positivity is
described whether there is implementable
'ti whether this course can be
implemented in the community with safety
that is well pathologist in the
community be able to replicate the
scoring that was implemented in during
the clinical trial and is it
reproducible and either
unlike are they all measuring the same
biology of questions that
that we ponder of as we review of each
of these applications and if the
analytical performance is marginal then
one of the things we need to think about
is how the clinical peptide and it's
definition is contributing ah to poor
analytical performance and it would be
we are also needed to assess if
clinically that point can be effectively
trained within the community for wider
use so among the other things that
impact clinical assessment is the
specimens and the variability in
specimen or pre-analytical that might
impact clinical outcomes and here I flag
the specimen data that we typically
request all device manufacturers to
obtain we ask them to keep a record of
the type of specimen deposited into the
study but as archival are it's a freshly
obtained biopsy and in a recent review
of the 22 c3 test for gastric cancer it
was determined that archival tissue the
PDL one had relative was relatively
unstable and archival tissue when
compared to newly obtained biopsies
which triggered or a limitation
statement requesting that if a archival
PDA one specimen is tested for patients
in in the clinic and you would return a
negative result it might be worth
exploring if a second biopsy is feasible
because the test result is not locked
down because of instability of the
antigen we ask for information on the
biopsy location whether it was or the
specimen location whether it was from a
primary site or a metastatic site
whether it was a resection specimen or a
biopsy specimen because this the way
these customs are handled might impact
what the type of results that they get
out because our biopsy person is a
handle very differently than the
sections questions and
the pre-analytical variability can
result in a different test result so be
request that all this data be collected
and included within the PMA application
to make an assessment of the factors
that might impact test results in other
parts so what are the analytical
validation studies having talked all
this while about how clinical validation
is perform at this time I'd like to
switch gears and go to analytical
validation and of one of the analytical
validation studies that are required
have a bit of a luck in the slide
loading our analytical validation is so
unethical validation and Here I am
listing all the of all the factors that
are important for an IHC test result and
here our analytical validation includes
the characterization of the assay in the
laboratory before it moves into a
clinical trial so the biochemical
characterization of the antibody so that
access and study and specificity given
that IHC tests use an antibody the
specificity of the antibody is
determined the precision including
reader precision has determined so the
precision is thus retesting over
multiple days using different Lots
between different laboratories our are
precise that you get results that are
reasonably similar ah what happens when
you test them across sites you remember
these are distributed kits so what
happens when they when they're
distributed and if they're tested at
more multiple site that's another draw
another important piece of analytical
verification that we are let be
routinely asked for acid robustness test
for the limits of the assay
the boundaries within which the asset
performs precisely yes say for a PCR
reaction it could be the annealing
temperature being moved around and for a
nyancy test it would be ah it would be
the target retrieval temperature and the
time and the pH of the buffer being used
if it were to vary by
some some amount around it's ideal what
are the impacts do you retain the
results do you not retain the results
there are the failure points also within
the analytical variables assessment of
pre analytics how the sample handling
impacts the presence of impurities
impacts test results is important to
assess of also understanding tumor
heterogeneity
whether it's within the tumor or primary
versus metastatic gives an understanding
of the type of specimens that would give
us the most reliable result within the
clinical setting the stability of the
reagents of the specimen also needs to
be defined so that the entire test
system is defined and its performance
within a window of China's well known
and if any controls are provided within
the test system those need to be
validated as well so what are the
faculty one takes into account during
analytical performance assessment it was
all you start from the test the test is
specimen to result so every step along
the way needs to be validated the
instrument the software the specimen
type the the pre analytical processing
that goes into it so the pre analytical
processing validation should be
performed with the intended specimen
type suppose the study is being
conducted in non small cell lung cancer
the specimen type with which the
analytical validation is performed
should be from non small cell lung
cancer and for molecular assays
sometimes controls customers for
challenging specimen types is to be can
be used and if contrast specimens are
used or what are the functional
characteristics of the country especi
means it should be well well-defined and
all studies should follow protocol
labeling so the labor should be locked
down much before any unlogical
the protocol for the test should be
locked up much before any analytical
study is initiated and studies should
demonstrate robustness at clinical Cara
so I talked about many different tests
with many different cut-offs and at each
of them the acid needs to show that for
specimens that exist around the cut
point
the study is that the performances of
robots and that there are a few false
positive and false negative and the
overall performance needs certain
acceptance criteria so a key validation
can be thought of as a mind matrix you
need to think of each component and each
of them need to be validated and here
I've opened it up to all types of assays
and all types of specimens so what you
do is if it's a PCR using whole blood or
plasma then the assay the instrument so
it's a PCR assay with whole blood plasma
and you're testing DNA so the DNA and
the outputs whether it's qualitative
well it's mutation in a particular gene
so when you download this matrix it
immediately becomes obvious the types of
things that one needs to do to validate
the assay and for molecular assays
additional or additional metrics are
need to be established such as limit of
blank limit of detection limit of
quantitation specificity or exclusivity
and accuracy against a valid comparator
or a reference method and god bonding
under busman's map to IHC's and
molecular tests very well and more
recently with a lot of NGS tests coming
online for for approvals of the approach
we have taken two analytical validation
is that for any test that detects
multiple genetic changes or multiple
mutations say a multiple multiple
mutations within the gene
each of the type of gene should be
analytically validated and you should
ensure that they can be detected and
multiplex asset such as NGS require
complex validation and if you look at
more recent approvals of the foundation
one follow-on companion diagnostic you
will see that the validation approach
takes into account representative
variations of gene sequencing tests and
again reiterating that analytical
validation should take into a trans
person and should be done with the
finals intended use person so for the
final leg of my talk and I think I'm
running out of time so I will move up
move through this a little faster than I
intended to UM one needs to keep in mind
that the companion diagnostic started as
a single analyte single or indication
with a single drug and the first example
of that is the her2 as analyte with her
said test and Herceptin in breast cancer
however as time has gone by and targeted
therapies have taken off of every
possible type of analyte indication and
drug has come through to the FDA for
approval and I will not go over each
particular case which you might be able
to go through this individually from one
unlight with many tests we have gone to
multiple tests for multiple genes with a
single drug they've gone to multiple
analytes and a single test for multiple
drugs and in each of these cases have
presented us with unique challenges and
FDA has tried to be flexible and nimble
in addressing concerns of safety and
effectiveness without hampering or
coming in the way of development of
these tests are slowing down access in
the market
and one of the one of the things that
I'd like to point out is the follow and
companion diagnostic a follow on
companion diagnostic would is our
version 2 or a version of horrid tests
that was not used in the registration
file for the drug the following year a
follow on companion diagnostic should
consistently and accurately select the
same intended use patient population
because it was not tested in the
clinical trial but what it needs to
determine is that it can identify the
same population that the originally
approved companion diagnostic into so
one of the ways that one can do that is
either testing the clinical trial
specimens from the original our study
with the new test which establishes that
it identifies the same population or
from the original originally approved
companion diagnostic device and this was
how robust Kayla's mutation test was
approved as a follow-on hour of it could
also be performed with a bridging study
which is a method of comparison which
says that we've taken the intended
intent to task population all the
patients who would be eligible for
testing when we test them with our with
the old companion diagnostic and our
version of the new companion diagnostic
for which we are seeking a train they
identify the same population now whereas
it's an analytical method comparison a
procure clinical sample set should be
one should be one to confirm that it is
the targeted population for which the
drunkest net and when there are discard
answers one needs a plan ahead of time
on how these the impact of discordance
will be determined and and also take
into account if these differences are
happening because of biases and how the
testing is done our our how does how
does these dis causes impact device
performance so we need to determine if
it's random or there is a bias in the
discordance are all the new
I call this test samples that are
testing positive with the new device
we're tested negative would be a clear
indication wise so having talked about
it I want to switch pairs and say talk
about the other challenges we have are
for raw for approving the diagnostic
test and how we have tried to make
things easier as you've seen with the
PDL one diagnostic devices each of these
tests have claims at multiple
indications and we decided the least
burdensome approach for clinical
validation would still be the
contemporaneous review of cedar and CDRH
for any given clinical indication so for
when the device came in for year three a
bladder cancer it was - reviewed by
cedar and CDR age and it still came from
a clinical trial but the unlit achill
validation data are for the 28th aid a
say I was done such that you could
leverage data from prior indications the
analytical validation should not change
the precision of the start of a device I
would hopefully not change just because
indications are changed so long as the
same unlight is being detected
so antibody specificity would not change
the tour of too mature of body studies
that are part of civilian specific are
not varied across studies so the
real-time stability are this real-time
stability in this case is the stability
of the reagents that are being used to
test various indications if one is
tabled for lung cancer there is little
reason to believe it will not be stable
for breast cancer are melanoma specimens
and if and the pre-analytical variables
given that the unlight is in the same
mind major so if it's an F of T then you
would imagine that nothing should change
and you shouldn't have to repeat those
studies so that when you have then you
have the same device being applied to
new tumour indications you could reduce
the amount of analytical validation
that's being performed and leverage data
from indications with prior
and towards the conclusion all I would
like to say is that this is an exciting
field biomarkers and immunotherapy are
very hot and everybody is excited to
explore and research in this area and
the exploration is taking the form of
many different tests gene expression
profiling for immune signatures is often
talked about and last may we have the
approval of Bob intruder for tissue
agnostic condition for mismatch repair
deficient or my satellite instability hi
are tumors so any tumor that is mismatch
repair deficient or might satellite and
stable would patient for the tumor with
that status would be eligible for
treatment with Cotulla after failure of
our therapies so these are new and
emerging biomarkers and another one
that's often discussed was a tumor
mutation bothered by NGS and here there
are many open questions and as I said
this is so in the biomarker stage where
you could determine tumor mutation
button either by doing whole exome
sequencing or doing gene panels and if
one by doing gene panels one of the
choice of gene panels are all genes that
you're testing in your panel equal and
permutation burden are some more favored
than not and what is the definition of
the cutoff so we see the same issues
that came up with is see coming up here
on how you define positivity how you
choose your cutoff what are the
underlying measurements that you need to
make or I on the right answer so each of
these biomarkers present us with similar
challenges as we go forward so in
conclusion what I would like to say is
that for a successful conversion of a
predictive biomarkers are to a companion
diagnostic it's useful to think about
establishing biomarker testing strategy
very early in clinical development and
if you collaborate early on with FDA and
you bring to both therapeutic center and
the diagnostic center of the existence
of the biomarker and a test associated
with it one could think
about all the possible ways in which to
mitigate the risk from development
developing or diagnostic tests because
of which a drug trial might fail or a
diagnostic test that is poorly designed
that might fail in itself so using the
pre submission process was critical for
our new development programs and
companion diagnostic and the sooner you
interact are the better in better shape
one is into developing a successful
program the last two slides give you
links to useful resources all companion
diagnostics that are approved by FDA is
listed at the website as I've flagged
here and below here are all the
guidances or that FDA reviewers are use
for review of companion diagnostic
devices with that I'd like to thank you
for your time and take any questions
that you might have thank you thank you
dr. Janaki Veda rod bun for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your questions
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for ok it looks like we have time
for one question our question is when
during the review does the companion
versus complementary status of the
Diagnostics made testing question oh and
I useful one to be aware of or if it is
an all car so a targeted population
trial where the drug this the intent to
treat population is also already
biomarker selected so only biomarker
positive subjects are enrolled into the
trial are only biomass and negative
subjects I enrolled into the trial so if
it is a Marcus elective trial it
is you into a companion diagnostic
paradigm that the test becomes essential
to identify the intent to treat
population ah
but as if it is an all-comers trial of
what could happen is that during the
course of review of between Bare cedar
and CDR HR contemporaneously review a
brings up questions so this happens
during the review process for the drug
and the device as I said both
applications are always reviewed in
parallel and when they are being
reviewed in parallel or the Center for
device and the Center for drop talked to
each other and determine the safety and
efficacy of both the drug the drug
review from cedar takes into account the
safety and efficacy of the drug and we
review the safety and effectiveness of
the device and in agreement with each
other make a decision and this usually
during the review process I hope that
answers
thank you for that answer any questions
not answered will be addressed via email
I would like to once again thank dr.
Janaki Veera Raghavan for her
presentation I would also like to thank
laberd's for making today's educational
left as possible before we go I want to
let everyone know the today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through May of 2018 you will receive an
email from Lavery's letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcements
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's last bet that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye